you know back in my day growing up in
the utopian garden of eden period known
as 1990s i did not
have sexual relations with that woman we
had kids shows which uh the interesting
thing about the kids shows that they
were they were shows for kids that's
what they were for and some of them were
better than others some were kind of
weird some were kind of stupid some were
artistic masterpieces like for example
the nickelodeon show salute your shorts
which is a 90s show that every 90s kid
remembers and then is shocked to
discover that every other 90s kid
remembers it too now the thing about
these shows is that their primary goal
was to entertain as i remember that's
different from the situation that we
have today where kids shows seem to
consider entertainment sort of a
secondary concern the primary goal now
is to ensure that the children in the
audience adopt the correct
political and ideological viewpoints
wheel of morality turn turn turn tell us
the lesson that we should learn what
were some kid shows that you watched
when you were little do you remember tom
and jerry i watched the smurfs and by
correct i mean those views that are in
keeping with the mainstream beliefs of
our culture and by that i mean incorrect
so by correct i mean incorrect we'll
begin with the latest example
and maybe the worst this one is fresh
out of the indoctrination oven it's the
show muppet babies in which gonzo comes
out as a gender-fluid cross-dresser yes
really
let's watch there you are you missed our
royal ball we met the most amazing
princess
but they ran away and all they left
behind was this
everyone there's something i need to
tell you
the princess who came to your ball
tonight
was me
[Music]
is a heterosexual male who's in love
with chickens okay so now they're trying
to make him they nope
it's a lie
okay first of all second of all this is
the most absurd thing ever they're using
they pronouns in mainstream programming
as if it's mainstream language and a
mainstream problem this is what we need
to be teaching the kids and what to
worry about yes it's very important is
that they they they don't know what they
are when they're five years old like
when they're the most impressionable age
i think they can be boys and girls that
won't have any negative effect on them
imagine if when i was five 20 years if
when i was little i thought that i could
be a girl or a they or you know that
that definitely doesn't have an effect
on kids expected me to look a certain
way i don't want you to be upset with me
but i don't want to do things just
because that's the way they've always
been done either
i want to be me
oh gonzo
we're sorry
it wasn't somebody
i love how did everybody hear them wrong
because that just that just came at the
most perfect time ever
it's very nice of us to tell you what to
wear to our mom you're our friend and we
love you any way you are
yeah yeah of course yeah
see this is why it's so important have a
father in the home it's clear that gonzo
doesn't have a father in the home to say
hey take that thing off you look stupid
get that thing off of you take that
ridiculous thing off
you know some people will point out oh
is this muppet babies that we're
watching okay so yes so the this is this
is gonzo's childhood and then he did
grow up to be a heterosexual male who
likes chickens apparently because this
is the best gonzarello would you relax
this is the prequel it's gonzarella no
it's not it's gonzo it's gonzarello um
the kid shows in the past have had
episodes where boys dress as girls and
and that's true uh but in the past
whether it was a kid show or something
for older kids or or you know older
audiences something like mrs doubtfire
movie from the 90s robin williams in the
past this plot point was always played
for laughs right it was supposed to be
funny the point was that boys look
stupid in girls clothes and we should
laugh about it
who cares what you think you're a girl
now
now the point is that wearing girl's
clothes is great and courageous and more
boys should try it you know if you've
raised your your kids correctly and they
and they were to watch them up at babies
and they saw that
they would start laughing like if my
boys watch my babies which they won't
but if they did and they saw they would
just laugh hysterically because they
would say that's so silly and ridiculous
which it is but now it's the the
the goal is quite the opposite of that
which is among other things extremely
creepy next we have the show arthur um
one that i remember from my childhood as
well the show about a lovable aardvark
i think that's what he is i could be
wrong he used to be lovable um anyway
he's lost a bit of his charm now that
he's pushing critical race theory hey
arthur
hey buster
do you see that video yeah i just
watched it it was awful i can't believe
someone would be hurt like that just
because they're black racism is so
unfair no one should ever judge someone
by the color of their skin but how could
it happen here in elwood city right
outside the sugar bowl buster it happens
everywhere
i was talking to mrs mcgrady the other
day she said there's a really long
history of black people not being
treated fairly in this country they
literally tell black kids from when
they're little that they're marginalized
and that they're like less than white
people they constantly tell them that
they're less it's it's crazy
it's so disgusting so when i was growing
up and when even when you were growing
up you know what they did they just they
we had very a lot of diversity in our
entertainment so they act like there was
oh everything was all white people all
the time [ __ ] every show i watched
had um racially ethnically diverse past
i love them and frankly we just learned
by example these people were just living
together nicely and they didn't have to
go
constantly harping and harping harping
so we learned by seeing we watched that
we carried it on and we we were just
nice to people now every time a little
kid sees somebody the first thing they
do is size them up by their by their
race and they either have pity on them
which is a [ __ ] insult to just meet a
total stranger and have pity on them i
dare i don't want you pity okay and if
somebody wants nobody wants hitti except
pity party people who want pity it's an
insult to look at someone and say uh
i would be embarrassed
they're less than me
i would be embarrassed if i was black
and every single time like you go on the
media all they're doing is talking about
how you're so marginalized and oppressed
and that you're less than white people
like that's just weird well i can say it
and then you know every time that
happens with women and they're just like
just like oh stop it already stop and
then you know what's even more
embarrassing is that the lgbts have
taken it like to make it their
responsibility to stick up and protect
the gay people so now they have gay
flags with like the african-american
symbol on it if they put like the
italian flag on that i'd be like what
the [ __ ] like what is this [ __ ] i know a
lot of black people and like especially
like tougher neighborhoods that just
like don't support that [ __ ] like at all
yeah that's just the reality of it just
stop we have to do something yeah
okay let's just say let's just say we
have to do something why on earth
let's say all this is correct right and
this is a real problem we need to
address with kids like it's it and it's
not and again some people have accused
me of uh dismissing racism as
non-existent i have never said that and
i do not say that i know it exists in
some people's wicked hearts but it is
not the problem that the mainstream
media makes it to be so now let's just
say for the sake of the conversation
that it is this big enormous problem and
it is our biggest prop national problem
why are you stressing out four-year-olds
with this [ __ ] you know why why can't a
kid just be a happy-go-lucky kid and
live its life wide as a child if you go
back like you have to lay in bed and go
why do i have to be white i'm such a
devil like what the [ __ ] is that why
would you do that yeah not only why am i
why do i have to be white why do i have
to be such a devil why am i black why am
i less than white people why do people
hate me just because i'm black and then
these black kids probably go around
thinking that they have a target on
their backs every time they see white
people they're like oh they definitely
don't like me they're out to get me it's
constantly putting up your guard for
something that doesn't even need to be
up it's just weird this is so [ __ ] up
to do the truth it's the purpose of its
purposeful divisiveness from when
they're little so that they're just it's
engraved in their brains that like the
other races are bad again keep us
divided we're easier to control
[Music]
what can we do i mean i'm eight i can't
even fry an egg on my own yeah i don't
shouldn't be thinking about this
maybe mrs mcgrady can give us some ideas
it's okay eight-year-old how to fry an
egg i think that's boys so they learned
something
dad you reached out to me
yes i saw the video too and let me tell
you it made my blood boil me too it also
made me scared i mean this happened in
our neighborhood it is scary buster
but you should know that a lot of
grown-ups are fighting racism and
working hard to keep us all safe a lot
of grown-ups fighting racism nothing but
racism that's all they focus on is that
really like the biggest problem nowadays
is [ __ ] racism is that not the
biggest problem out of all the [ __ ] that
you could be worrying about you have no
money you're you're out of shape and
you're worried about racism i went
shopping today and meat is up like forty
fifty percent the price of me that's a
bigger problem for everybody than racist
and the thing is like people can't
afford to feed their family if there
actually was racism like there was like
60 years ago yeah would be more of a
problem than now but like they're just
there isn't as much racism they're over
inflating it again maybe i'm just being
naive i just think that they're over
inflating it making it the biggest
problem when it's pretty clearly not get
the [ __ ] out of here why does this keep
happening mrs mcgrady well racism is
like a disease if you don't treat it
it's just gonna get worse okay let me
jump in there mrs grady if i could uh
mrs mcgrady whatever your name is why
does it keep happening well for the same
reason that unicorns keep sitting on
your roof
that is it's not happening
like at all there have been
comparatively few unjustified police
shootings
of anyone um statistically
this is this is undeniable from a
statistical standpoint i can just tell
you though that if all you tell kids is
race and then that's that's what you
tell them is bad and you can't say then
when kids want to say [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's going to be the first thing they
go to so ultimately you're just making
people more racist and you're increasing
racism by constantly talking about this
because kids say [ __ ] up [ __ ] and they
say what they like they say what is not
acceptable you're not supposed to say
that's the first thing they go to
because like you're oh yeah no no i'm
sorry i'm cutting off the baby no no i
was cutting you off no i was i remember
when i was little and like i told i
already talked about this in the video
the first time someone mentioned race
and like how black people are looked at
differently i was like this is so weird
like i have my my black friend like i
never even thought of him as different
until these weird teachers and stuff
started mentioning it so if all you talk
about it from when you're little it's so
god it has to be so negative on their
heads what were you going to say uh i
think it's a comedian john milady if
you've never seen it watch his clip on
how afraid he is of middle-aged kids
because the way he explains he's
hilarious the way he explains it is a
middle-aged kid will find the thing
about you that you are most insecure
about and they will make fun of you for
it exactly that's the truth and that's
just their nature children are exploring
good and bad and being you know what it
feels like to be a jerk and what it
feels like to bully and be bullied and
that's just that's just the way it goes
because not everybody grows up in uh you
know a perfect household like the brady
bunch where everything is just happy and
people are constantly loving and kind so
let's get real let's keep it real kids
are gonna so the more the more things
you now you're pointing out all the
things that kids can torture each other
for okay great yeah feeding it feeding
the racism i i just have my [ __ ]
broken record they're doing this on
purpose because divided in united we
stand divided we fall that is one of our
national mottos we know it and it is so
true and they're just really leaning in
on the divided we fall apart and almost
none of them
have any connection to racism
so this is not a thing that's actually
happening and yet yet the people behind
arthur
want small children to imagine they live
in a country where black people are
being killed left and right for the
color of their skin just like walking on
the street they're just getting murdered
by the cops you really think someone
would do that just go on the internet
and tell lies and by the way side note
what what does does race even exist in
the arthur universe you can't just
invent a holiday arthur well sure you
can
my family celebrates kwanzaa and that
was invented for african americans by dr
molana karanga in 1966.
not sure what's going on there exactly
but let's keep going uh we'll stay on
the on the racial side of things with
this from a show that i don't even know
what the show is but it's called steven
universe here it is
oh god
all right class can anyone tell me who
invented the light bulb
that's not entirely true the light bulb
could more rightfully be attributed to
lewis latimer the black inventor behind
the filament inside the bulb
this invention made light bulbs
affordable and efficient enough for the
general public bringing electric light
into households around the world well so
now you know
wait is that it hold on we're not going
to mention why he invented the filament
to create a better standard of living
for people who had only just been freed
from slavery oh she just looks like an
evil liberal teacher too even in a
cartoon just the pink hair so we gotta
roll slavery into science like instead
of teaching these children the science
behind the filament she's just gonna go
on some kind of a race tirade these
bozos all they want you talking about is
race they don't want to teach you
anything real i'd also like to back up
for one second and just
make it clear to everybody this is this
looks like it's a cartoon network show
i've never seen it before arthur haram
arthur and um is a is a public
television cartoon so it is i will it is
um either produced by wgbh here in
boston or the other um it's it's big
affiliate in new york and it's
distributed nationwide on national
public television which basically means
that it is government-funded so it's
government-funded programming they have
grants from um the nih national
institute of the humanities and you know
all kinds of different government
agencies that give grants to arts
organizations and wgbh is the largest
public television station that produces
shows like this excuse me they're the
largest recipient of these grants so you
literally have government money behind
this the governments control what you
think of schools they control what you
think watching on tv they control social
media we've learned that that if they
don't want something getting out on a
social media platform they just go
behind the back door tell the head guy
and they're like no this isn't this
isn't a good time you're like
you know what i just saw on tv today it
that is crazy that everything they're
all sitting around the table but
facebook twitter google paypal and all
the all the things sitting around the
table going how are we gonna how are we
gonna shut this one down because this
one we don't like it imagine figuring it
out together no i was saying i was
watching a commercial on um on tv and it
was like a guy in a classroom and he's
like the healthiest thing you can do for
like to get back to school is get
vaccinated like the best way to stay
healthy is get vaccinated like ram and
that's that's what you're saying on tv
the best way to stay healthy is to get
exercise and eat healthy not go outside
or not and yeah
it builds up a natural immune these
people are hilarious remember when when
there was like a hurricane coming in and
they're they're like oh yeah hurricane
don't don't worry about anything else
get vaccinated now's the time to go get
vaccinated
let me be clear
if you're in a state where hurricanes
often strike
like florida or the gulf coast or into
texas a vital part of preparing for
hurricane season is to get vaccinated
now are we going to ask why kids are
apparently learning about thomas edison
and not learning about lewis latimer
these textbooks are incomplete there
were black roman warriors black medieval
knights black classical musicians black
cowboys black fighter pilots where are
they
okay okay why can't she just
instead of making it this this big thing
against black people just say oh that
was awesome he created the light bulb oh
and here let me tell you about another
invention and find a black inventor and
just put just put it in there and make
it a positive thing instead of draping
everything
in pain and negativity why are these
people so attached to misery they are so
wedded they love it so much misery
misery misery that's what you've chosen
i don't want to get into a historical
debate with a cartoon but at the same
time no you could not attribute the
light bulb to lewis latimer if you
actually care about things like the
truth and historical accuracy you know
those
little details like that yes
latimer innovated a filament for the
bulb he didn't invent the filament but
he did come up with a better
longer-lasting filament which is great
that doesn't equate to inventing the
light bulb all right i could invent a
more durable
tire or a more reliable
braking system well i couldn't do that
but somebody could that doesn't mean you
invented the tire or the braking system
whoever did it first like yeah he did a
better version [ __ ] whoop like big
deal they can teach that he didn't
invent the [ __ ] light bulb that
doesn't mean that i get to claim that i
invented the car though and i can't
defend the car because it's already been
invented so there's that little detail
as for the actual inventor of the light
bulb there is a debate that could be had
about who exactly that was edison
deserves
most of the credit that he gets joseph
swann is an english scientist also
developed in incandescent bulb
independently but joseph swann was white
so the fact is many of the most
important
inventions in modern society
were given to us by white people usually
men not all but a great many that's not
a racist statement that is just a fact
it's also not something to be ashamed of
or embarrassed about or competitive
about or angry about rather than trying
to steal this invention from thomas
edison
when he's not even around to defend
himself how about saying hey thanks
thomas adam edison
there at least one good good uh white
guy that's been out there there are many
others it turns out
um all right so no list of woke children
shows would be complete without the
blues clues drag queen episode which
maybe you've seen by now but it's got to
be on the list so let's all
enjoy that once again hey blue look at
all these families hi families it's time
for a pride parade
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah
families marching one by one hurrah
hurrah this family has two mummies they
love each other they're so proudly and
they all go marching in the big parade
families marching four by four hurrah
no no i want to see i want to see what
is this family special special thing
families marching four by four hurrah
hurrah
trans members of this family all love
each other so proudly and they all go
marching
the big parade come clean the fun this
by the way is a show for preschoolers
high schoolers preschoolers have to be
worried about sexual and romantic
relationships
[Music]
do you know what a typical plot for
blue's clues used to be
steve who it was the guy
he would lose his glue stick
and he'd have to find it
and he would ask blue hey blue do you
know where my glue stick is
and blue would be all
uh coy about it even though blue knows
what the damn glue stick is he won't
just tell steve where it is so he starts
planting all these clues around the
house and steve is very patient he's
like okay i gotta go through i'll do
that we're gonna spend 30 minutes
looking for the damn glue screw you just
tell me where it is blue but he doesn't
do that he actually goes and so that
would be that's the whole episode it's
just
is just steve trying to find his glue
stick and at the end he finds it
and that's the end of the show
that was a kids show
and now we have i remember we watched
four years we watched an old episode of
spongebob like a month ago at my
friend's house and i was like wow this
this used to be kind of funny like
stupid jokes the whole time nothing too
serious no political agenda you know
when i was little you didn't want me
watching like those kinds of kids shows
was there a reason behind it no there
was one um i wish i could remember the
exact example but we can dig it up
sometime and find it but you used to
look sunny loved thomas the train so we
had every piece of thomas merchandise
you could ever imagine in the house and
he played with them all the time and we
also had a lot of the dvds one time i
came in and i sat down and i watched one
with them and i heard them just spouting
this marxist communist [ __ ] like
what like i can't remember that's why i
just started saying i can remember i
will find it and i will share it with
you all and i said i can't believe that
they're teaching kids this so this isn't
brand new but this has now gone off the
rails and uh i will find it and we will
uh we'll share it because i at that
point turned it off i was like we're not
watching thomas anymore we just stopped
watching it and we started watching
normal things where you were taught
manners and kindness and little funny
games like oh my god the glue stick's
missing ha ha oh my god will i ever find
it you know that that was enough for
your three-year-old mind more than
enough pansexual toads
and bisexual turtles singing about their
favorite sexual orientation so a little
bit of a different approach i suppose
okay one more we'll close with um
lesbian horses on my little planet let's
watch this
we truly have a gift for helping ponies
oh thanks aunt holiday
oh was that it okay um
i i you know i was i was waiting because
well first of all i didn't mean to
misgender the horses that's actually not
a horse that's a unicorn it would seem
but you know how bad it's gotten
that that that was the tamest thing
we saw i was like waiting for that was
downright quaint and conservative in
comparison to what you normally get from
kid shows these days a lesbian couple on
my little pony
the lesbian unicorns they're not even
into like bdsm or anything there's no
subplot where one of them gets a sex
change
this is old-fashioned
really yeah
that's how bad it's gotten
and it's just one more reason why
you should turn the tv off
send your kids outside let them go run
and play
scrape their knees
bloody their noses a little bit
minor injuries await them outdoors but
at least
they'll still have their souls i hired a
new dietitian well not a new dietitian i
hired a nutritionist to help me with my
diet so i can stay on top of it for
mental clarity so i can be on top of
business and everything and just tell
the story first so part of it includes
eating raw eggs in the morning so cause
you know because we're gonna you know
you're gonna gain muscle mass and have a
high protein diet and all that stuff
sunny and i were talking about it today
and i was like are you really gonna do
this raw egg thing and he's and he kind
of was like i have to i said i will do i
will eat one raw egg with you out of
solidarity never in my life have i ever
done this i remember watching it in on
rocky rocky is my favorite movie of all
time okay and and rocky he does it in
the morning he eats like i think he has
six eggs he cracks them all into a glass
and drinks them all before he goes
jogging and it just looks like the most
disgusting awful thing ever so we're
gonna do this right now we're gonna eat
an egg
[Music]
[Music]
won't last long